Batman is a fantastic fictional
inspiration for many of us as an example
of someone who's built not only
incredible power but incredible speed
endurance mental prowess he is a peak
human being he is the pinnacle of what
we all can hope to accomplish through
sheer grit and determination and like
someone like Superman he doesn't have
any super powers he only has his own
will and his own training methods in
this series I've been breaking down what
those training methods might be and how
we might apply something similar in a
real-world setting
last time I talked about how Batman
might train using leverage tools such as
the club Bell and the kettle bell to
build strength at unusual angles real
functional power in this part two we're
going to build on that concept using
powerful gymnastic strength training as
well as metabolic conditioning using
calisthenics I'm going to take some cues
from CrossFit so without wasting any
more time let's get straight to it
so jumping straight in we've already got
our kettlebells and our club bells
another kind of training that is
functional in all of the right ways is
gymnastic strength training or
calisthenics learning how to control
your own body weight building that kind
of agility and control the prior section
is incredibly useful for anyone is going
to be leaping across rooftops and
getting into brawls at the same time
this is also a brilliant way to build
more stability and strengthen the core
and again to attack the body from angles
that otherwise go overlooked in
particular for Batman I think that
gymnastic rings and also weighted
calisthenics makes a lot of sense
gymnastic rings requires intense control
grip strength and the ability to brace
yourself through the entire movement and
weight the calisthenics makes a lot of
sense for a guy who carries a ton of
equipment around on his belt including
shark repellent anyways probably about
40 kilograms of armor every single night
this will allow us to continue to build
more strength of something heavy whilst
at the same time slightly simplifying
movement to reduce the chance of injury
and also in place is a high energy
demand on the body so it's great for
building work capacity endurance and
mental toughness but that's not the only
kind of calisthenics that I want to be
doing I also want to add in simpler more
explosive calisthenics that means things
like push-ups pull-ups and clapping
push-ups even of course explosive
plyometric work like clapping push-ups
is fantastic for building explosive
strength whether you're snapping out a
rapid punch or whether you need to throw
something along distance at the same
time though these kind of simple
explosive calisthenics moves are perfect
for metabolic conditioning we can use
this as a form of resistance cardio that
means that we're performing high volume
high repetition in order to tax our
aerobic system burn calories and
challenge our body's energy efficiency
but at the same time because we're still
using our muscles because they're still
resistance we're going to avoid burning
through muscle and we're gonna build our
work capacity and our strength endurance
Batman spends all night when across
rooftops getting two huge brawls it's
not enough to be strong for a short
period of time we need to build that
kind of resistance recently our sparring
grants as you guys saw in the last video
and I was completely expecting to get my
ass whooped
I haven't trained for a long time and he
eats breathes and sleeps martial arts I
mean you guys have seen him and I wasn't
disappointed he indeed did work for my
ass
one of the reasons for there's something
on ice is very early on is how quickly I
got gassed out and exhausted partly this
was because my movements weren't very
efficient especially compared to his
this is partly due to a lack of practice
but also due to my karate training my
blocks were extremely enthusiastic also
I'm just an enthusiastic guy but also
because I'm just not used to that kind
of exertion and that's why this sort of
metabolic conditioning is perfect for
Batman so going to add these kind of
circuits at the end of our workouts and
say for example you might do as many
pull-ups as you can due to failure then
take just a 30-second rest and then do
as many pushups as you can - failure
repeat this six times resting no more
than thirty seconds by the end your
muscles will feel pumped and swelled
with blood and at the same time you'll
be gasping for air and a break this is a
fantastic way for anyone to very quickly
very simply increase their work capacity
what's at the same time building more
cost ability and strength as well as
increasing their pull-up count and their
press-up count every time you do this
you've got to try and beat your previous
score by at least one where possible and
that will help me to continue to exert
more to be more explosive and to be more
enduring along with the calisthenics
were also going to be using some
resistance cardio finishers that means
things like the battle ropes
once again you're using your muscles so
you're protecting yourself against
breaking down muscle but at the same
time you're challenging yourself to
exert force for long stretches of time
just like Batman would need to of course
another form of resistance cardia the
Batman would definitely be doing lots of
his bag work to not only train his
martial arts but also just as another
excellent form of high-intensity
interval training and explosive training
I recommend that you do three sets of
three minutes with a one-minute break in
between use each one to focus on
something different a different skill or
a different technique recommend checking
out grants video on his Bruce Lee
inspired to drill and at the same time
this is Batman I highly recommend that
you train both Orthodox and southpaw
because Batman is definitely
ambidextrous it gives him a huge
tactical advantage and it's also another
reason why we're focusing so much on
unilateral movements here as well as
contralateral movements
finally on one of the routines I've been
having alternating Sprint's with pull
ups and push ups
this is what you call cardio
acceleration and it basically means that
in between sets instead of resting
you're going to be running or performing
some kind of cardio that ensures that
your heart rate is high for the entire
movements thereby taxing you there by
burning three more calories and
challenging you in a completely
different way cardio acceleration I
think is a perfect fit for Batman style
workouts because it mirrors the kind of
dynamic performance is gonna need when
he's out patrolling for instance you
might need to get into epic battle chase
someone across a rooftop and then
continue fighting it's one thing to
better lift a heavy amount of weight
it's quite another to be able to do that
when you're already exhausted and you
might have noticed that this is very
similar to CrossFit that's one of the
main ideas behind CrossFit CrossFit in
many ways is the perfect fit for Batman
training and if you look at the Batman
files if you watch the Batman vs
Superman training montage or if you read
many of the fictional Batman training
programs written by fans you'll see that
CrossFit in general comes up a lot it's
a perfect fit for Batman's kind of cross
modal training the problems with
CrossFit come from the fact that a
you're only using certain lifts it's a
competition so you're focusing on
specific types of movement and also the
inherent risk with doing high-volume
squats and deadlifts if you're doing a
hundred deadlifts after going for a run
then you're quite likely to injure
yourself my aim with this program is to
have our cake and eat it we're gonna be
training cross-modal and we're going to
be using resistance cardio and metabolic
conditioning we're going to be using
strength training as a form of metabolic
conditioning what we're going to be
doing differently is placing the complex
and difficult movements at the start of
the workout and then the easier more
explosive less injury prone movements
towards the end we're still challenging
our work capacity but when we do the big
heavy complex lifts
we're not exhausted and we're not likely
to injure ourselves at the same time I'm
stopping out there's more traditional
movements for more complex and unusual
things like the bench press and the
Turkish getup
I've spoken about Batman's mental
training in a previous video and in a
future video I'm going to talk about his
skill acquisition so we don't wanna go
into that in depth and now however I
think what's important to recognize is
the connection between the body and the
mind
such that it makes sense to train both
at the same time wherever possible when
we look at things like egg bodied
cognition it becomes apparent just how
closely linked these things are we use
our body to understand the world we
can't have one without the other so I
wanted these workouts to not only
provide stimulation to the body but also
for the mind and that's one of the
reasons that they include so many
different and unique movements you might
not have used before when you learn any
new movement is fantastic for
neuroplasticity the more you use your
brain to learn the better it becomes at
learning and the quicker you can learn
those additional skills once you master
all these complex hybrid exercises and
things like the Turkish getup
start introducing new concepts into your
training you keep your body agile and
flexible so it can keep adding new
strings to your bow and learning
movement is one of the very best forms
of learning because it involves so much
sensory input we're using for preception
which is going to enhance our senses
lots of these movements involve balance
and I'm going to add a couple more
things as well firstly before you begin
your workout I recommend that you do a 5
to 10 minute
body scan meditation you can find
instructions on how to do this all over
the web but basically it involves
sitting with your eyes closed
and focusing on contracting then
releasing and relaxing each muscle
starting from your forehead all the way
down to your toes what this is going to
do not only will have all of the
benefits of any form of meditation
improving focus grain method development
etc but it also helped me to develop the
mind muscle connection to strengthen the
connection between the sensory motor
cortex and each muscle in other words
you're reminding your body where that
muscle is and you're using it and
feeling it so that you can regain that
sensory input from it and so that you
can recruit that force development more
when you need it this is also a
fantastic opportunity to do some
Diagnostics meaning in other words that
you're listening out for any aches or
pains or stiff muscles and that help to
avoid injury during the workout that
follows
[Music]
right at the end of each of these
workouts have included a quasi isometric
I made a video on that so check out if
you don't know what these are basically
it involves going through a movement
extremely slowly such as an S squat or a
pull-up it's gonna take you a full
minute to complete the entire range of
motion what this does is it allows you
to really focus on the movement to feel
which muscles are using to identify any
issues with your technique any areas
where your weakest we normally speed
past and at the same time it's a
fantastic opportunity to do some mindful
movement and this is another form of
meditation that has been used for
centuries and practices like Tai Chi and
like shaolin kung foo we're using it
here in combination with the quasi
isometrics to get some muscle building
performance gains at the same time and
it's a fantastic cool-down which will
prevent blood from pooling in your
muscles which can lead to dizziness and
nausea and finally at the end of the
workout I think you should finish with
five minutes of hakalo meditation I've
talked about this before my Ultra
instinct video basically means engaging
a peripheral vision staring forwards but
not at any point in particular this has
been shown to be either lower your heart
rate there's another great opportunity
to clear your mind and practice focus
and determination and it's a tool that's
used by Special Operations operatives
when they're scanning a crowd for a
potential target and by survivalists
when they're walking through the woods
and looking out for hazards or things to
eat of course this will be used with
Batman in terms of his situational
awareness but also when surveying a
crime scene looking for clues and
provide a benefit train either with bare
feet or with very minimal soles and so
helped me to develop further prior
section and put strength and train
outside whenever possible because you'll
get more bit of D you'll get more fresh
air but at the same time when it's cold
when it's wet it'll build your grit and
determination and that really is
Batman's main superpower his discipline
and his ability to Train no matter what
for his singular end goal so that's the
Batman workout in a nutshell we're
focusing a lot on kettlebells
and Club bells because they allow us to
train our body at different angles we're
putting specific emphasis onto single
arm movements onto contralateral
movements on two movements that train
the transverse or the frontal plane
we're going to use these to build raw
strength they're all angles in
combination with the prior section
balance and control we're gonna be using
hybl exercises to make it extra
difficult and then moving through to
powerful controlled gymnastic strength
training with rings and with weighted
calisthenics we're going to be using
mechanical drop sets just as we did in
the first Batman training
and the entire thing is gonna be a kind
of drop set built like a power building
program except with the emphasis on
complex movements followed by simpler
and more explosive movements performed
in a metabolic conditioning fashion and
if you don't have all this equipment if
you don't have a club bell for instance
then you can always MacGyver it a good
alternative to a club bell is just a
dumbbell with the weights only on one
end a good alternative to a rope and I
also recommend a rope climbing for a
million-in-one reasons is a towel
wrapped over a pull-up bar
don't let anything put you off this
workout just take these ideas and adapt
them into your own training program of
course if you want the full program the
full workout was I recommend doing it
and check out the link in the
description down below they'll take you
to the bio near where you can find that
in future I'm gonna be going over topics
like Batman's and recovery like his
skill acquisition and like his nutrition
so now I'll just say in terms of
nutrition make sure that you drink lots
of water eat lots of calories and eat
lots of protein get a nutrient-dense
diet and remember Batman's not
interested in having ripped abs so we
don't need to get down to 5% body fat
provide yourself with the right amount
of fuel for this intensive training
program and like I said check out the
link in the description down below for
the super functional ebook and training
program that takes everything I've
learned on this channel and combines it
into a single routine and provides tons
of in-depth information to help you
understand it and adapt it to your own
lifestyle if you enjoyed this video and
if you want to train more like Batman
then you might well enjoy that so check
it out thanks a ton to all of you for
watching I hope you have a fantastic
Christmas and New Year and I'll see you
very soon with lots more like this
subscribe if you're interested comment
down below and I'll see you next time
thanks a ton for watching and bye for
now
in a guy's talk it to you here from the
bio mobile which is a Ford Fiesta so
probably more like a dad mobile just
wanted to quickly say that if you head
over to the patreon I'm gonna be
uploading a full uncut version of this
video who combines part 1 and part 2
into one piece the way it was meant to
be viewed every now and then I upload
exclusive content to the patreon so if
you're interested in seeing that then
find the link in the description down
below I've been out to up the production
value on these videos by subscribing to
invite oh elements that's where I get
all of the cool music and the cool stock
footage I've been able to invest in some
new equipment like the cool LED lights
and in future soon I'm gonna be
upgrading my camera and my sound system
so hopefully the quality will improve
even more and if you're interested in
becoming a patron then this will be the
perfect time to do it because in the new
year I'm gonna be creating a new
Facebook group a bio near group which
will be invite-only and they were gonna
talk about all the cool stuff all the
underground training or the brain
training that we discuss here on the
channel so if that sounds cool then
check it out and thanks again for
watching and yeah Merry Christmas and
Happy New Year